Si América Latina no está envuelta en alguna
crisis es que no es América Latina: pobreza,
desigualdad, golpes de estado, revueltas,
movimientos populistas que surgen hasta debajo
de las piedras, recuentos dudosos… La lista
es muy larga.
Sin embargo, si en algo parece estable, muy
estable, esta región es todo aquello que
respecta a su integridad territorial.
Pero…. ¿Y si os dijéramos que existe un
conflicto que se ha ido cocinando a fuego
lento y que ahora podría, literalmente, partir
en dos el cono sur?
¿Queréis saber exactamente de qué estamos
hablando? Pues… Atentos.
Pero, antes quiero haceros un anuncio muy
especial: Estamos en año de mundial, así
que hemos querido preparar algo súper novedoso
que creemos que os va a encantar: La liga
VisualPolitik.
De la mano de nuestros amigos de Biwenger,
hemos puesto en marcha una liga Fantasy, dónde
podremos competir entre todos. Participar
en la Liga VisualPolitik es algo muuuuuy sencillo
y, por supuesto, totalmente gratuito. Y además
podréis conseguir un montón de premios:
Simplemente tenéis que seguir el enlace que
os dejamos en los comentarios y en la descripción,
y una vez os descarguéis la app de Biwenger
- si es que no la tenéis ya os llevará directamente
a nuestra liga.
Entonces tan sólo tendréis que asignar un
nombre a vuestro equipo y… Listo, ya estaréis
preparados para gestionar vuestro propio equipo
y enfrentaros a Fonseca, a Alberto y a mi.
Tendréis ver que jugadores ficháis, que
jugadores vendéis, preparar la alineación,
el sistema y escoger a vuestro capitán. Luego,
en función de los resultados reales tendréis
más o menos puntos.
¿Confías en la nueva apuesta de Laporta
y la Xabineta 2.0 y crees que Lewandowski
se va a salir? ¿Crees que este será el año
de Valverde y los hermanos Williams en el
Athletic? ¿Piensas que Ancelotti seguirá
su racha triunfal y que jugadores como Benzema
o Modric seguirán al máximo nivel? Pues
ya sabéis lo que tenéis que hacer.
Dicho esto arranquemos
Queridos amigos, amigas, como todos sabéis
Chile y Argentina son los dos países más
meridionales, esto es situados más al sur.
Ambos se independizaron del Reino de España
a inicios del siglo XIX, así que ya suman
más de 200 años de trayectoria en solitario.
Claro que esa no es toda la historia. Sus
territorios hoy comprenden espacios y jurisdicciones
que antiguamente estaban ocupadas por distintas
comunidades indígenas, entre ellas los mapuches:
un pueblo originario de América del Sur radicado
en el centro de Chile y el sur de Argentina,
en lo que hoy se conoce como La Araucanía
chilena y la patagonia argentina.
Pues bien, el caso es que si hasta ahora esta
etnia había vivido en paz tanto con los argentinos
como con los chilenos, eso ahora ha cambiado.
Los últimos años se han caracterizado por
una escalada de la violencia que, incluso,
ha obligado al gobierno de Chile a militarizar
parte del país. Concretamente, desde el año
2009, algunos grupos mapuches muy radicalizados
mantienen una creciente y abierta lucha contra
los estados de Chile y Argentina por el control
del territorio.
C1 (“Dado que no ha existido ninguna señal
del gobierno de poner fin a las fuerzas represivas
en nuestras comunidades, hemos tomado una
decisión como Coordinadora Mapuche Arauco-Malleco.
Manifestamos públicamente nuestra renuncia
a la nacionalidad chilena, y declaramos territorio
de la nación autónoma mapuche.” Comunicado
público en 2009 de la Coordinadora Mapuche
Arauco-Malleco)
Este comunicado supuso la punta de lanza de
la crisis actual. Ahora bien, ¿en qué consisten
las reclamaciones mapuches? ¿Qué las ha
motivado? ¿Hasta qué punto peligra la integridad
territorial de Chile y de la Argentina?
En este vídeo vamos a responder a todas estas
preguntas, pero para entender cómo se ha
llegado hasta esta situación antes, antes
tenemos que ver, ¡Un poco de historia!
T1 (INGREDIENTES PARA EL CONFLICTO)
Para conocer dónde comenzó el problema tenemos
que remontarnos hasta el siglo XIX. En aquel
momento la sociedad mapuche estaba construida
sobre un complejo sistema de alianzas matrimoniales
entre las familias más poderosas. Pero, ¿Cómo
se definía el poder de cada grupo? Pues fundamentalmente
por su capacidad ganadera y, especialmente,
su capacidad para relacionarse con las fuerzas
coloniales.
En este sentido, los mapuches eran un grupo
poco centralizado en sus relaciones de poder.
De hecho, la propia concepción de un “pueblo
mapuche” se solía interpretar como una
construcción básicamente occidental. Esto
es así porque en realidad esta comunidad
indignera era muy heterogénea, lo que resultaría
clave en distintas etapas.
Pero, por ahora, no nos desviemos.
Con la independencia de Chile y Argentina
entre los años 1810 y 1818 surgió un nuevo
escenario para las relaciones políticas de
los mapuches, quienes a partir de ese momento
tuvieron que acostumbrarse a negociar con
los nuevos gobiernos nacionales.
El problema fundamental es que estos gobiernos
tenían el objetivo de forjar, consolidar
y cohesionar sentimientos de nación en los
territorios independizados. Es decir, se enfrentaban
a la tarea de construir el concepto de nación
chilena y nación argentina.
Pues bien, para cumplir con dicho objetivo
era esencial integrar 3 conceptos clave: sociedad,
estado y territorio. Sin embargo, tras echar
a la corona española, los gobiernos de las
nuevas repúblicas se dieron cuenta de que
gran parte de su teórico dominio territorial
se encontraba erosionado por las jurisdicciones
bajo control de comunidades indígenas como
los mapuches, comunidades que de hecho y tal
y como podéis ver controlaban la mayor parte
del nuevo territorio libre.
En otras palabras, que para los políticos
de la época estos grupos suponían un claro
impedimento para su proyecto de construcción
nacional.
Durante la mitad del siglo XIX ambas repúblicas
ya habían avanzado desde su capital hacía
el sur, sumando cada vez más terreno para
su proyecto político. Un proceso que no fue
regular sino que se fue dando de forma intermitente
por el constante surgimiento de diferentes
conflictos internos.
El caso es que, de esta forma, durante la
segunda mitad del siglo XIX, el Estado chileno,
ya mucho más organizado se vió con la capacidad
suficiente como para publicar en 1866 un decreto
que establecía que todas las tierras sobre
las que no se pudiera comprobar una ocupación
mapuche efectiva y continuada por el periodo
de un año, se pasarían a ser consideradas
como terrenos baldíos y el estado procedería
a subastarlos. Comenzó así una cruzada militar
conocida como la ““Ocupación de la Araucanía”.
En ese momento, gran parte de las comunidades
mapuches se pasaron al lado argentino para
evitar ser alcanzadas por las tropas chilenas.
Pero su tranquilidad duró poco.
En 1878 el estado argentino puso en marcha
un proceso similar al de China, con la conocida
como “Conquista del Desierto”, una operación
a gran escala que había sido precedida por
operativos similares en el sur de la Provincia
de Buenos Aires.
Tras estas dos campañas, los mapuches pasaron
de ocupar 10.000.000 de hectáreas a verse
concentrados en poco más de 500.000. Es decir,
perdieron el 95% del terreno que controlaban.
Y desde luego por el camino sufrieron muchas
bajas. Aunque a este respecto hay que decir
que las estimaciones de los diferentes historiadores
actuales varían mucho.
Tras llevarse a cabo estas dos campañas político-militares,
tanto el estado argentino como el chileno
dieron por solventada la cuestión territorial
y comenzaron a construir un estado moderno
bajo el principio de “gobernar es poblar”.
De esta forma se generaron los incentivos
suficientes como para atraer desde Europa
enormes flujos de inmigrantes que cambiarían
por completo la realidad local.
Por ejemplo, se estima que en el año 1920,
casi la mitad, la mitad de todos los habitantes
de Buenos Aires habían nacido en el exterior.
T2 (EL SIGLO XX BAJO LA ALFOMBRA)
Durante comienzos del siglo XX, con los mapuches
diezmados en el mapa, con una sociedad nueva
de inmigrantes europeos, una economía próspera
y un mundo dominado por el conflicto, el asunto
indígena desapareció por completo de la
agenda pública… Aunque, por supuesto, eso
no significó que la realidad mapuche y sus
reivindicaciones desaparecieran por completo.
Poco a poco la situación económica y política
se fue complicando en ambos países. De la
inestabilidad de mediados de siglo se pasó
a los golpes militares de los años 70 lo
que dio paso a la dictadura militar de Jorge
Rafel Videla y sus sucesores en la Argentina
y a la de Augusto Pinochet en Chile.
Y fue, precisamente, la dictadura chilena
quien en 1976 creó el Consejo Regional Mapuche
como un órgano asesor para favorecer el vínculo
del estado con la población indígena de
la Araucanía chilena. El tema mapuche volvía
a estar sobre la mesa.
Y de hecho, esta región, la Araucanía chilena
fue una de las únicas 2 regiones de todo
Chile dónde el plebiscito que desplazó a
Pinochet del poder le fue favorable al dictador.
Sea como sea, lo cierto es que a partir de
mediados del siglo XX volvieron a registrarse
protestas, actos reivindicativos y redadas
que en cierto modo podemos considerar como
el embrión de la situación actual.
Por ejemplo, entre los años 60 y 50, se produjeron
acciones de resistencia contra la construcción
de represas y programas de explotación agrícola.
Esto ocurrió especialmente en el centro de
Chile.
Con todo, la llegada de la democracia a Chile
y Argentina entre los 80 y los 90, dio pie
a que surgieran nuevas instituciones estatales
para intentar establecer vínculos más estrechos
con las comunidades indígenas. Por ejemplo,
en 1985 se creó en la Argentina el Instituto
Nacional de Asuntos Indígenas y en 1992 se
fundó en Santiago la Corporación Nacional
de Desarrollo Indígena.
Claro que, visto lo visto, no parece que estas
organizaciones lograran sus objetivos.
Pero, sea como sea, así es como llegamos
al siglo XXI, un periodo de tiempo dónde
ahora sí, el conflicto mapuche se ha puesto
al rojo vivo.
Atentos.
T3 (ESTALLA EL CONFLICTO)
Vale, la historia de los mapuches es mucho
más compleja, pero creo que con todo lo que
hemos visto tenemos más que suficiente para
comprender los orígenes del problema, al
menos sus claves principales¿No os parece?
Pues bien, ahora que ya estamos situados,
estamos preparados para viajar hasta el año
2009, el año en el que se produce la declaración
de guerra.
Queridos amigos, amigas, son muchas las comunidades
mapuches que no se sienten ni argentinas ni
chilenas, sino que para ellas, ambos estados
significan exactamente lo mismo: la represión
contra sus ancestros y en cierto modo su cultura.
Claro que aquí tenemos que hacer dos apuntes
importantes:
Ni todos los mapuches han asumido un clima
belicista ni la situación en Chile y en Argentina
son plenamente equiparables.
Y es que veréis, según el censo poblacional
de Chile del 2017, aproximadamente 1.7 millones
de personas en este país se declararon pertenecientes
al pueblo mapuche. Esto supone aproximadamente
el 10% de la población total del país.
Por su parte en Argentina el peso mapuche
es mucho más reducido. Hablamos de aproximadamente
205.000 personas que se auto reconocen como
mapuche en todo el país, apenas un 0,5% de
la población argentina.
Por supuesto, no hay casi 2 millones de personas
alzadas en armas contra el gobierno chileno
y el argentino, al menos hoy por hoy. Si fuese
así la historia sería muy diferente-
Pero, ¿recordáis que los mapuches no solían
organizarse bajo un liderazgo centralizado?
Pues… Exactamente eso mismo sigue ocurriendo
hoy en día.
Así, que no, no existe una entidad que los
englobe a todos y los persuada de tomar parte
en una resistencia armada.
De hecho, de los cientos y cientos de miles,
casi 2 millones de chilenos y argentinos que
se identifican como mapuches, solo una fracción
milita en agrupaciones violentas. Es decir,
la inmensa mayoría de las personas que forman
parte de esta comunidad convive de forma pacífica
e interactúan con las instituciones nacionales.
Esto es algo muy importante que tenemos que
tener en cuenta para evitar errores de interpretación
o que se estigmatice como violento a todo
el pueblo mapuche.
De hecho si algo nos dice la evidencia histórica
es, precisamente, que estigmatizar y etiquetar
a todo un pueblo suele ser la mejor forma
de empujarlo a la radicalidad.
El caso es que con el paso del tiempo han
surgido movimientos bien organizados y armados
que han provocado la actual espiral de violencia.
Este es el caso, por supuesto, de la conocida
como Coordinadora Mapuche Arauco-Malleco,
pero no es el único. En 2014 también surgió
la Resistencia Ancestral Mapuche, con un comunicado
que dio la señal de alarma en la región.
C2 ("No queremos integrarnos, queremos liberarnos"
(...) Ni argentinos ni chilenos, somos Nación
Mapuche. Todo el territorio libre y recuperado
para todo nuestro pueblo" Resistencia Ancestral
Mapuche)
¿Recordáis las campañas llevadas a cabo
por los ejércitos chilenos y argentinos que
consideraron a los mapuches un problema común?
Pues parece que ahora la historia regresa
en forma de boomerang.
De hecho el 31 de mayo del 2022, la Cámara
de Diputados de Chile declaró a las organizaciones
que véis en pantalla como “asociaciones
ilícitas de carácter terrorista”.
C3 (“La Cámara de Diputados declara a las
organizaciones “Coordinadora Arauco-Malleco”,
“Resistencia Mapuche Malleco”, “Resistencia
Mapuche Lafkenche” y “Weichan Auka Mapu”
como asociaciones ilícitas de carácter terrorista,
y requiere de S. E. el Presidente de la República
su persecución penal de conformidad con lo
dispuesto en la ley N°18.314 sobre conductas
terroristas. Resolución 135 del 31 de mayo
de 2022)
Pero ahora bien… Exactamente, ¿en qué
consiste la liberación mapuche?¿Qué territorio
reivindican hoy en día? ¿Concretamente con
qué argumentos justifican la acción armada?
Pues bien, lo que hoy buscan liberar y recuperar
estas agrupaciones se conoce como “WALLMAPU”,
y comprende el centro tanto de Chile como
el de Argentina, dividiendo a ambos países
literalmente por la mitad. De hecho, la propia
capital chilena estaría dentro de este territorio.
¿Os imagináis a estos dos países partidos
literalmente por la mitad y a Chile trasladando
su capital? ¿No, verdad? Pues… Hay quienes
han tomado las armas para conseguirlo. De
momento se trata de un nivel de violencia
no muy alto pero que tiende a ser más o menos
constante.
Por ejemplo, para el 2017 la situación había
devenido en una espiral de violencia sin precedentes
que obligó a los gobiernos de Maurició Macri
y Michelle Bacheler a empezar a poner en marcha
planes conjuntos para combatir los focos de
violencia. El propio Sebastían Piñera, ganador
de las elecciones ese mismo año en Chile,
prometió mano dura y la aplicación de la
ley antiterrorista.
Y es que podemos decir que el conflicto empezó
así:
N1 (31 de Marzo 2012: Microempresarios dueños
de camiones quemados en La Araucanía: Quedamos
arruinados y aterrorizados
N2 (Enero 2013: El conflicto mapuche enciende
Chile)
N3 (Noviembre 2014: Grupo mapuche se adjudicó
incendios en Bariloche y declaró "la guerra"
a Chile y Argentina)
Continuó de esta forma:
N4 (8 de Octubre de 2017: Piñera aseguró
que la CAM es terrorista y está financiada
desde el exterior)
N5 ( 20 de Julio de 2018: Mauricio Macri,
sobre el conflicto mapuche: “Nadie puede
creer que está por encima de la ley”
N6 (25 de septiembre de 2018: Chile anuncia
un plan para apaciguar a las minorías mapuches
)
Y actualmente nos encontramos tal que así:
N7 (18 de julio de 2022: Chile: 20 vehículos
quemados en nuevo ataque en conflicto mapuche.
CNN)
N8 (Tras nuevos ataques de grupos radicales
mapuches, empresarios y legisladores chilenos
exigen extender el despliegue militar. Infobae)
C4 (“La violencia, previsiblemente, va a
escalar en la zona mapuche” Salvador Millaleo,
experto en el conflicto mapuche y ex-asesor
de Gabriel Boric)
Por si fuera poco el movimiento mapuche ha
ido poco a poco adquiriendo un cierto tinte
anticapitalista para hacerse con el apoyo
de los movimientos de izquierda en América
Latina.
C5 (“El Control Territorial debe ser entendido
como un proceso de carácter autonomista en
relación al Estado y a sus instituciones,
y anticapitalista”. Comunicado de la Coordinadora
Arauco Mapuche (Enero 2019)
Así que ahora la lucha por recuperar el territorio
mapuche es también una lucha contra el neoliberalismo
y el capitalismo internacional. [Ver para
creer]
Pero claro, entre 2019 y 2021…. Los gobiernos
de estos dos países pasaron a estar dominados
por políticos de izquierdas. Así que la
pregunta es, ¿qué pensáis que hicieron?
Pues… Atentos.
T4 (SORPRESA EN EL ESTADIO: MANO DURA DESDE
LA IZQUIERDA)
Hubo un momento en el que parecía que los
gobiernos de izquierda podrían llegar a pactar
con los grupos mapuches. El problema es que
aunque estos se han escorado ideológicamente
hacia la izquierda, su principal reivindicación
sigue chocando frontalmente con la propia
configuración estatal de estos países. Incluso,
podríamos decir, con la mismísima existencia
de Chile y Argentina tal y como hoy los conocemos.
Y eso, eso es lo que explica noticias como
estas:
N9 (16 de Mayo de 2022: Gabriel Boric volvió
a militarizar el sur de Chile ante el aumento
de la violencia)
N10 (20 de Mayo 2022: El Gobierno chileno
advirtió que las Fuerzas Armadas “responderán”
si son atacadas durante el estado de emergencia
en el sur)
N11 (Junio de 2022: Renuevan por un nuevo
periodo estado de excepción en La Araucanía
y provincias de Arauco y Biobío)
Para sorpresa de muchos, el presidente de
izquierdas chileno, Gabriel Boric ha decido
continuar e incluso impulsar la política
de mano dura de Sebastian Piñera.
Lo, por cierto, parece chocar con sus propias
palabras del 11 de marzo, el día en que fue
investido presidente:
C6 («Lo que sucede en La Araucanía es un
conflicto entre el Estado chileno y un pueblo
que tiene derecho a existir, y la solución
no es ni será la violencia». Gabriel Boric,
Presidente de Chile)
Desde entonces el cambio no ha podido ser
más radical:
C7 (“Si se quieren utilizar esa demandas
(de los pueblos indígenas) para enfrascar
o disfrazar el crimen organizado, el narcotráfico
u otros eventos delictivos (...) nuestro Gobierno
va a ser claro, enfático y no va a descansar
en perseguir y encontrar a los responsables”.
Izkia Siches, Ministra del Interior de Chile)
Pero, vale, esta es la situación en Chile,
pero, ¿qué está ocurriendo en la Argentina?
Pues digamos, que envuelto mil crisis y con
un gobierno partido en mil pedazos, no parece
que el presidente Fernández tenga tiempo
para esta cuestión. Claro que el problema
en Argentina es, como hemos visto, mucho más
pequeño que en Chile. Afecta a 20 veces menos
porcentaje de la población. Así que mientras
las cosas no se salgan de madre en el otro
lado… Pues, digamos, que parece que se lo
pueden permitir.
Aunque esto en Santiago de Chile no haga ninguna
gracia.
Queridos amigos, amigas, para muchos analistas,
de no cambiar las tornas, la actual situación
en torno al conflicto mapuche puede ser el
antecedente a una espiral de violencia mucho
mayor que puede llegar a provocar un choque
inédito en la historia de América del Sur.
Pero llegados hasta aquí, turno para ti:
¿Sabías que Argentina y sobre todo Chile
enfrentaban semejante problema territorial?
¿Cómo piensas que puede resolverse esta
situación? ¿Crees que llegará el día en
el que ambos países pierdan el control sobre
esta parte del territorio? ¿Qué opinión
te merece este conflicto?
Dejadnos por aquí abajo vuestros comentarios
y abramos debate. Por supuesto si este vídeo
te ha resultado interesante no olvides darle
a like y suscribirte a VisualPolitik.
Muchas gracias una vez más por estar ahí.
Un saludo y hasta la próxima.